make sure she gets it okay hey I'm the
driver you call the Tacoma girlfriend
not a girlfriend man
oh credit card was invalid this is your
first sequel right and denzel's for a
sequel what was it about this movie this
story that said you know what we're both
gonna do something that we've never done
before the people I mean you know it's a
response from the people man it's like
you know you can want to make a sequel
you can want to do all that but if they
don't go see it
you're not going to do it but also man
over four years four years ago right I
run into people in the airport different
places and the people come up to me to
ask you about the equalise you're gonna
make another one you're gonna find out
more about us wife you know what kind of
assassin or CIA guy was he you know so
you realize that people are actually
interested in that character and there's
outgoing that again so that else make a
decision you're not gonna ask me if you
got home okay okay I'm gonna need
anything you might have used to record
what you did here tonight
[Music]
[Music]
what's different about this one versus
the last one much more emotional the
stories go deeper it's a little more
complex story this past us come to
hunting we do take you home where you
from where he lives
it's got much more complex storytelling
get up you know a nice loser
her name is Amy given your left hand it
was a Star Trek very good five stars for
Amy something that sets up for a part
three are you looking that far yet for
you man I'm just trying to get this one
out in front of the audience you know to
be listen it's always alive when
somebody says oh I'm thinking about that
on all of course but you try not to
because you just want to make sure you
deliver I mean it's like one fight at a
time seen you Karen all those books
around I figured you for some kind of
teacher from a high level paid from an
assassin
[Music]
you